last time we considered the relationship
between pseudo-random graphs and their
eigenvalues and the main message is that
the smaller your second largest
eigenvalue is the more pseudo-random a
graph is in particular we were looking
at this class of graphs that are dreg
you know there are somewhat easier to
think about and there's a limit to how
small the second-largest eigenvalue can
be and that was given by the alone open
a bound you should think of D here as a
fixed number so here D is a fixed
constant then as the number of vertices
becomes large the second largest eigen
value but the irregular graph cannot be
less than this quantity over here so
this is a limit to how small the second
largest eigen value can be and last time
we gave a proof of this bound by
constructing an appropriate function
that witnesses this lambda to we also
gave a second proof which proves a
slightly weaker result which is that the
second largest eigenvalue in absolute
value is at least as quantity so in
spíritus amounts to roughly the same
result although technically it's a
little bit weaker and that one we prove
by counting walks and also at the end of
last time i remarked that this number
here the fundamental significance of
this number
is that it is the spectral radius of the
Infinity regular tree
okay so that's why this number is here
of course we proved some lower bound but
you can always ask question is this the
best possible lower bound maybe it's
possible to prove a somewhat higher
bound and that turns out not to be the
case so that's the first thing that
we'll see today is some discussions I
won't show you any proofs by some
discussions why this number is best
possible and this is a a very
interesting area of graph theory goes
under the name of Graham illusion graphs
okay so I explain the history in a
second why they're called Ramanujan
graphs Ramanujam did not study these
graphs but they're contemplations okay
so by definition a ram anujan graph is
ad regular graph such that if you look
at it I can value of the adjacency
matrix as above the second largest eigen
value in absolute value is at most that
down up there to root t minus 1 so it's
the best possible constant you could put
here so that there still exists
infinitely many T regular gamma Newton
graphs for fixed E and the size of the
graph going to infinity the last time we
also introduce some terminology I mean
just repeat that here so this is in
other words an ende lambda graph with
lambda and most to root t minus 1 now it
is not hard to obtain a single example
of a Ramanujan graph so I just want some
graph such that or the top eigenvalue st
i want the other ones to be small so for
example if you get this clique it's d
regular here the top eigenvalue is d and
it's not too hard to compute that
all the other eigenvalues are equal to
exactly minus one so this is an easy
computation but the point is that I want
to construct graph so I want to
understand whether there are graphs
where D is fixed so this is somehow not
a good example what we really want is
fixed E and n going to infinity large
number of vertices and the main open
conjecture in this area is that for
every D there exist infinitely many
Ramanuja and D regular graphs so let me
tell you some partial results and also
explain the history why they're called
Ramanujan graphs so the first paper
where this name appeared and coined this
name and I'll explain the reason in a
second is this important result of
dubofsky Phillips and Cernik from the
late 80s okay so their paper was titled
Ramanuja graphs so they proved that this
conjecture is true okay so the
conjecture is true for all D such that D
minus 1 is a prime number
I should also remark that the same
result was proved independently by
Margules at the same time their
construction of this graph is a specific
KD graph so they gave an explicit
construction
of a Kenny graph with the group being
the projective special linear group PSL
to queue okay so some some group this
kind of group Asher comes up a lot it's
it's a group with lots of nice pseudo
randomness properties and to verify that
the corresponding graph has to decide I
can value properties they had to invoke
some deep results from number theory
that were related to ram anujan
conjectures so that's why they called
these graphs ram anujan graphs and
that's an odd name stuck okay so these
papers they proved that these graphs
exist for some special values of D
namely when D minus 1 is a prime there
was a later generalization in the 90s by
Morgenstern generalizing such
constructions showing that you can also
take D minus 1 to be a prime power and
really that's pretty much it
for all the other values of D it is open
whether there exists infinitely many D
regular Ramanuja graphs in particular
for P equal to 7 it is still open do
there exist infinitely many seven
regular ramanuja graphs now what about a
random graph if I take a random graph
what is the size of its largest second
second largest eigenvalue and there's a
difficult theorem of friedman i say
difficult because the paper itself is
more than 100 pages long that if you
take a fixed e then a random and vertex
D regular graph ok so what does this
mean so the easiest way to explain the
random deregulate
graph is that you look at the set of all
possible D regular graphs on a fixed
number
disease and you pick one uniformly at
random so random such graph is almost
Ramanujam in the following sense that
the second largest eigenvalue in
absolute value is at most to loot t
minus one plus some small error root or
one where the little one goes to zero as
n goes to infinity so in other words
this constant cannot be improved but
this result doesn't tell you that any of
these graphs are Ramanujan experimental
evidence suggests that if you take in
the for fixed value of T let's say T
equals to 7 or D equals to 3 if you take
a random D regular graph then a specific
percentage of those graphs are Ramanujam
so the second largest eigen value has
some empirical distribution at least
from computer experiments where some
specific fraction I don't remember
exactly but let's say 40 percent of
3-burner graphs is expected in the limit
to be Ramanujan so that appears to be
quite difficult we have no idea how to
even approach such conjectures there
were some exciting recent breakthroughs
in the past few years concerning a
variant somewhat weakening of this
problem I borrow a bipartite analog of
ram anujan grass now in a bipartite
graph so all by part i graphs have the
property that its eigenvalues its
spectrum is symmetric around 0 its
smallest eigenvalue is minus T so if you
plot all the eigenvalues its symmetric
around you this is not a hard fact see I
encourage you to think about it and
that's because if you have an
eigenvector okay so it lifts somewhere
on the left and somewhere on the right
I can form another eigenvector which is
obtained by flipping the signs on one
part so that I have the total if the
first eigenvector has eigenvalue lambda
then the second one has eigen value
minus lambda so the eigenvalues coming
symmetric pairs you know in a Ramanujan
graph if I okay so by definition a
bipartite Ramanujam graph is one where
it's a bipartite graph and I only
require that the second largest
eigenvalue is less than 2 root D minus 1
everything symmetric around the origin
so this is by definition if you start
with a ram anujan graph i can use it to
create a bipartite ram anujan graph
because if i look at this to lift so
what whether is this construction this
means if i start with some graph G so
for example if G is this graph here what
I want to do is take two copies of this
graph think about having the amount 3
sheets of paper one on top of the other
and I draw all the edges criss-crossed
so that's G cross 2 this is G you should
convince yourself that if G has
eigenvalues lambda then G cross K 2 as
eigenvalues the original spectrum as
well as its symmetric so it's negation
so if G is ram anujan
then G cross K 2 is a bipartite graph
newgen graph so it's a weaker concept if
you have our Minuten graphs then you
have bipartite Ramanujan graphs but not
in Reverse
okay so there was a but still I promise
- there exists the irregular bipartite
Ramanuja graphs is still interesting
it's somewhat weaker pombe is still
interesting and there was a major
breakthrough a few years ago by Markus
Spielman and Srivastava showing that for
all fixed deep there exist infinitely
many D regular bipartite Ramanujan
graphs and unlike the earlier work of
new boskie philips and sonic which the
earlier work was an explicit
construction of a cainy graph this
construction here is a probabilistic
construction it uses some very nice
tools that they called interlacing
families so it showed probabilistically
using a very clever randomized
construction that these graphs exist so
it's not just take a mutual deregulate
random bipartite graph but there's some
clever constructions of randomness okay
and this is more or less the state of
knowledge regarding the existence of
Ramanujan graphs again the big open
problem is that there exists D regular
ram anujan graphs for every D there
infinitely many such ram anujan graphs
yep
right so the question is in if you start
with ad regular graph and take this
construction the spectrum has one D and
it also has a minus D so a bipartite
graph if if your graph is bipartite its
spectrum is symmetric around the origin
so you always have D and minus T so
bipartite graph can never be Ramanuja
but the definition of a bipartite
Ramanujam graph it's just that I only
require that the remaining eigenvalues
sit in that interval i okay with having
- teacher so that's by definition of a
bipartite Ramanujan graph any more
questions all right
so combining a lone bump on a bound
versa and both the existence of ram
anujan graphs and also Friedman's
difficult result that random graph is
almost Ramanujan we see that this root
to 2 root D minus 1 that number there is
optimal okay so that's the extent in
which a D regular graph can be
pseudo-random now the rest of this
lecture I want to move on to a somewhat
different topic but still concerning
sparse pseudo random graphs basically I
want to tell you what I did for my PhD
thesis okay so so far we've been talking
about
pseudo random graphs but let's combine
it with the topic in the previous
chapter namely similarities regularity
lemma and we can ask can we apply the
regularity method to sparse graphs when
we talk about similarities regularity I
kept emphasizing that it's really about
dense graphs because there are these
error terms which are little ol N
squared and if your graph is already
sparse that error term is of everything
so for sparse graphs you need to be
extra careful so I want to explore the
idea of a sparse regularity and here
sparse just means not dense so sparse
means X density so the opposite of dense
we saw the triangle removal level so let
me remind you the statement it says that
for every epsilon there exists some
Delta such that if G has small number of
triangles then G can be made triangle
free
by removing a small number of edges okay
I would like to state a sparse version
of this theorem that works for graphs
where I'm looking at sub constant edge
densities so roughly this is how it's
going to go I'm going to put in these
extra P factors and it's just think of P
as some quantity that goes to 0 with
with them so what I would like is to say
that if so think of P as the general you
know scale right so that's the the
density scale we're thinking of I would
like to say that if G has less than that
many triangles then G can be made free
by deleting a small number of edges what
a small mean here small should be
relative to the scale of edge densities
you're looking at so in this case we
should add an extra factor of P over
here so that's the kind of statement I
would like but of course you know this
is too good to be true because we
haven't really modified anything if you
read the statement is just completely
false so I would like to add in some
conditions some hypotheses that would
make such a statement true and
hypothesis is going to be roughly along
the slice so I'm going on there's a
method theorem because I won't state the
hypotheses precisely but roughly it will
be along the lines that if gamma is some
is a sufficiently pseudo-random graph
n vertices and each density P and G is a
sub graph of gamma then I want to say
that G has this triangle removal
property relatively inside gamma and
this is true or it is true if you put in
the appropriate sufficiently
pseudo-random condition so I'm leaving
here I'll tell you more later what this
should be so this is a kind of statement
now I would like so a sparse extension
of the triangle removal lemma says that
if you have a sufficiently pseudo-random
host where you think of this gamma as a
host graph then inside that host
relative to the density of this host
everything should behave nicely as you
would expect in a dense case the dense
case is also a special case of the
sparse case because if we took gamma to
be the complete graph which is also
pseudo-random it's everything uniform
then then this is also true and that's
that's trying to remove all imine the
dense case but we want the sparse
extension question
where does pee come in to soapy here's
the edge density of gamma yeah so you
should think of so I'm again I'm not
really stating this so precisely but you
should think of P as something that
could decay with n not too quickly but
decay at end to the - some small
constant yep correct so question is does
what is Delta depend on so here Delta
depends on only epsilon and in fact what
we would like and this will indeed be
basically true is that Delta is more or
less the same Delta from the original
triangle removal lemma yep
okay so the question is if G is some
arbitrary graph what's to stop you from
making a sub graph of a large pseudo
random graph and so it's a great
question if I give you a graph G can you
test whether G satisfies the hypothesis
because the conclusion doesn't depend on
gamma depends only on G but hypothesis
requires us to gamma and so my two
answers to that is one you cannot always
embed it in a gamma right so for example
if you are so I guess the easier answer
is the conclusion is false
without the hypothesis so you cannot
always embed it in such a gun but it is
somewhat difficult to test whether I
don't know a good way to test whether a
given G like since such a gamma I'll
motivate this theorem in a second why we
care about results of this form yes okay
so the question is if you start with a
sufficiently large pseudo-random gamma
there's a contain every copy of G and
the answer's no because G has the same
number of vertices as gamma so a
sufficiently large are sufficiently
pseudo-random again I haven't told you
what sufficiently pseudo-random inva
means yet but you should think of it as
having controlling small patterns but
here G is is a much larger graph it's
the same size it's just maybe let's say
half of the edges so what you should
think about it starting with gamma being
let's say random graph and I delete
either serially let's say half of the
edges of gamma and you get G okay so let
me let me go on and if there please ask
more questions right so this is I won't
really prove anything today but it's
really meant to give you an idea of you
know what this line of work is about and
I now also I want to motivate it by
explaining why we care about this kind
of theorems so first observation is that
it is not true without the hypothesis
hopefully all of you see this is
obviously too good to be true
you know we'll also see some specific
examples here here's a specific example
so so this is not true
without this gamma so for example you
can have this graph G and we already saw
this construction that came from barons
construction where you have n vertices
and n to the 2 minus 2 to 1 edges where
every edge belongs to exactly one
triangle if you plug in this graph into
this theorem you know without the hyper
with all the yellow stuff if you add in
this P you see it's false just cannot
remove and so but what in what context
can we expect such a sparse triangle
removal I'm out to be true one setting
for which it is true and this was a
result that was proved about ten years
ago is that if your gamma is a truly
random graph so this is true for a
random gamma if P is sufficiently large
and roughly it's at least so there's
some constant such that if P is at least
C over root n then it is true so this is
the result of color and cowers
yeah it's always so this is random in
the erdos-renyi sense so address to any
random graph but this is not the main
motivating reason why I would like to
talk about this technique the main
motivating example is the green-tailed
theorem so remind you that the
green-tailed theorem says that the
primes contain arbitrarily long
arithmetic progressions so the quintile
theorem is in some sense an extension of
Samaras theorem but a sparse extension
similarities theorem tells you that if
you have a positive density subset of
the integers then it contains long
arithmetic progressions but here the
primes
we know from prime number theorem that
the density of the Prime's up to n the
case like 1 over log n so it's a sparse
set but we would like to know that it
has all of these patterns it turns out
the Prime's are in some sense
pseudo-random but that's a difficult
result of proof and that was proved
after green cowl proved their initial
theorem by later works of green and tau
and also Ziegler but the original
strategy and also the later strategy for
their stronger result as well but the
strategy for the green Cottenham is this
you start with the primes and you embed
the primes in a somewhat larger set
you start with the primes and you embed
it in a somewhat larger set which we'll
call informally pseudo primes and these
are roughly speaking numbers with is no
small prime divisors because these
numbers are somewhat smoother compared
to the primes they're easier to analyze
by analytic number theory methods
especially coming from safe theory and
it is easier although still highly
non-trivial to show that these pseudo
Prime's are in some sense pseudo random
and that's the kind of pseudo-random
host that corresponds to the gamma over
there
so the green Tao strategy is to start
with the primes build a slightly larger
set so that the prime set inside the
pseudo Prime's in a relatively dense
manner so the relative density is so
it's small so it has high relative
density and then if you had this kind of
strategy for sparse triangle removal
lemma but imagine you also had it for
various other extensions those sparse
hyper graph removal lemma which allows
you to proof summerlee's theorem and now
you can use it in that setting then you
can prove summerlee's theorem in the
Prime's so that's that's the theorem and
that's the that's the approach and
that's one of the reasons at least for
me why something like the sparse
triangle removal EMA plays a central
role in this kind of problems okay
so I want to say more about how you
might go about proving this type of
result and also what pseudo random graph
means over here
so remember the strategy for proving the
triangle removal lemma and of course all
of you guys are working on this problem
set and method of regularity hopefully
should be very familiar to you by the
end of this week but let me remind you
that there are three main steps one
being to partition your graph using
regularity lemma the second one to cling
and the third one to count and I want to
explain where the sparse regularity
method fails right so you can try to do
everything the same and then you know so
what happens if you try to do all these
things so first let's talk about a
sparse regularity lemma
so let me remind you previously we said
that a pair of vertices is epsilon
regular if for every subset U of A and W
of P neither too small
okay so if neither are too small one has
that the number of edges between U and W
differs from what you would expect so
that the density the edge density
between U and W is close to what you
expect which is the ordinal edge density
between a and B so they differ by no
more than epsilon okay so this should be
a familiar definition what we would like
is to modify it to work for the sparse
setting and for that I'm going to add in
an extra P factor so I'm going to say
epsilon comma P regular if well this
condition here now all the densities are
on the scale of key which goes to 0 as n
goes to infinity so in order to properly
compare them I should add an extra
factor of P to put everything on the
same on the right scale otherwise this
is too weak and ok and given this
definition here we can say that a
partition of vertices
is epsilon regular if oh but and most
epsilon fraction pairs is epsilon
regular so an equitable partition and I
will modify it to the sparse setting by
changing the appropriate notion of
regular to the sparse version where I'm
looking at scales of PEEP I still
require a most epsilon fraction that
stays the same that's not affected by
the density scale previously we had a
regularity lemma which said that for
every epsilon there exist some M such
that every graph has an epsilon regular
partition into at most M parts and the
sparse version would say that if your
graph has density edge density here most
P okay here all of these constants in
the cone shape oh so when I say P I
really could mean like a hundred times P
you just changed this constants so it's
most P then it has an epsilon comma P
regular partition into at most M parts
here M depends only on epsilon okay so
previously I wrote down the sparse
triangle removal Emma and I wrote down
the stamen and it was false right so
without the additional hypotheses it was
false
it turns out that this is actually true
the version of the sparse regularity
lemma which sounds almost too good to be
true initially we are adding in a whole
lot of you know sparsity and seems no
sparsity seems to be more difficult to
deal with and the reason why I think you
know sparsity is harder to deal with is
that in some sense there are a lot more
sparse grass than they are dense graphs
ok so let me pause for a second and
explain that it is not true that in some
sense there are more sparse graphs
because if you just count you know once
you have sparse or things there are
fewer of them but I mean in terms of the
actual complexity of the structures that
can come up when you have sparse or
objects there's a lot more that can
happen in dense objects similarities
regularity lemma tells us in some sense
that the amount of complexity in a graph
is bounded but that's not the case for
sparse graphs in any case we still have
some kind of sparse regularity lemma and
this version here as written is
literally true if you have the
appropriate definitions and more or less
we have those definitions up there but I
want to say that it's misleading this is
true but misleading and the reason why
it is misleading is that in a sparse
graph you can have lots of intricate
structures but that are hidden in your
irregular parts it could be that most
edges are in side irregular parts
irregular pairs which would make the
regularity lemma a somewhat useless
statement because we do the cleaning
step you clean up
delete all of your edges and you don't
want that but you in any case it is true
and now coming on the proof in a second
but the way I want you to think about
the sparse regularity lemma is that it
should work when okay so before jumping
to that specific example where this
happens is for example if your graph G
is a clique a sub linear fraction of
vertices I somehow you might care about
I click right so that's a pretty
important object in the graph but when
we do the sparse regularity partition it
could be that the entire clique is
hidden inside a an irregular part and
you just don't see it like that
information gets lost the proper way to
think about the sparse regularity lemma
is to think about graphs G that satisfy
some additional hypotheses so in
practice G is assumed to satisfy some
upper regularity condition an example of
such an hypothesis is something called
node n spots
meaning that it doesn't have a really
dense component like in the case of a
clique on a very small number of
vertices so no ten spots one definition
could be that there exists some eight
huh and here I'm you just as in quasi
random graphs I'm thinking of sequences
going to zero so there exists a tower
sequence going to zero and a constant C
such that for all
X in the graph let's say x + y if x and
y have size at least 8 a fraction of e
then the density between x and y is
bounded by a most a constant factor
compared to the overall density P that
we're looking at so in other words no
small piece of the graph has too many
edges
and with that notion of the no 10 spots
[Applause]
we can now prove the sparse regularity
lemma under that additional hypothesis
and basically the proof is the same as
the usual similarity regularity lemma
proof that we saw a few weeks ago right
so if you proof of sparse regularity
with no dead spots hypothesis and the
reason is that okay so I claim this is
the same proof similarities regularity
lemma and the reason is that in the
energy increment argument so you do
everything the same you do partition if
it's not regular you refine and you keep
going in the energy increment argument
one key property we used was that the
energy was bounded between 0 and 1 and
every time you went up by epsilon to the
fifth and now the energy increment
argument that each step the energy goes
up by something which is like Epsilon
let's say to the fifth and P squared
that's the energy some kind of mean
square density so this P squared should
play a play a role but ok what is the so
if you only knew that then the number of
iterations might depend on P it might
depend on n so not a constant and
that'll be an issue however if you have
no ten spots so because
so no then spots the final energy I
claim is at most something like C
squared P squared maybe some small error
because of all the epsilon is flowing
around but that's the final energy so
you still have a bounded number of steps
so the bound only depends on epsilon so
the entire proof runs through just fine
okay so having the right hypothesis
helps but then I said you know the more
general version without the hypothesis
is still true okay so how come that is
the case because if you do this proof
you run into the issue you cannot
control the number of iterations and so
here's a trick introduced by Alex Scott
so who came up with that version there
okay so this is a nice trick which is
that instead of using x squared the
function as energy let's consider a
somewhat different function so the
function I want to use is V of X which
is initially quadratic so initially x
squared but up to a specific point let's
say two and then after this point I make
a linear
okay so that's the function I'm going to
take now this function has a couple of
nice properties one is that you also
have this boosting this energy increment
step because for all random variables X
that are so axis non-negative random
variable so think of this as a densities
between parts on the refinement if the
mean of X is at most one then if you
look about if you look at this energy it
increases if X has a large variance
previously when we used fee as square
this was true so this is true with equal
to one in fact that's the definition of
variance but this is inequality it's
also true for this function fee so that
when you do the irregularity breaking if
you have irregular parts then you have
some variance in the edge densities so
you would get an energy boost but the
other thing is that we are no longer
worried about the final energy being
much higher than the individual
potential contributions because if you
end up having lots of high-density
pieces they would contribute a lot so in
other words
if you have so the expectation the
second thing is that the expectation of
fee is upper bounded by let's say four
times the expectation of X and so this
inequality there would cap the number of
steps you would have to do you would
never actually end up having too many
iterations okay so this is a discussion
of the sparse regularity lemma and the
main message here is that the regularity
lemma itself is not so difficult it's
largely the same as some radius
regularity lemma and so that's actually
not the most difficult part of sparse
triangle removal em'ly the difficulty
lies in the other step in the regularity
method namely the counting step and we
already alluded to this in the past the
point is that there is no counting lemma
for sparse regular graphs and we already
saw an example where if you start with a
random graph which has a small number of
triangles and I delete a small number of
edges corresponding to those triangles
one I do not affect its quasi randomness
but - there's no triangles anymore so
there's no triangle counting level and
that's a serious obstacle because you
need this counting step so what I would
like to explain next is how you can
salvage that and use this hypothesis
here retain yellow to obtain a counting
lemma so that you can complete this
regularity method that would allow you
to prove the sparse triangle removal
lemma and a similar kind of technique
can allow you to do the green tile
theorem so let's take a quick break okay
any questions so far
so let's talk about the counting memo
alright so in the counting lemma so the
first case of the country memo we
considered was the triangle hunting memo
remember if you have three vertex sets V
1 V 2 V 3 such that between each pair it
is epsilon regular and edge density
let's for simplicity say they all have
the same edge density actually taking me
different so T sub I J so they're
possibly different edge densities but I
have the set up and then the triangle
can't Annamma tells us that the number
of triangles with one vertex in each
part is basically what you would expect
in the random case namely multiplying
three these three edge sensitives
together plus a small error and then
multiplying the vertex sets sizes
together okay so what we would like is a
statement that says that if you have
epsilon P regular and edge densities now
at scale P then we would want the same
thing to be true here I should add an
extra P cubed because that's the
densities we're working with and I want
some error here okay I can even let you
take some other epsilon but small
changes are okay
okay so that's the kind of statement we
want and this is false so this is
completely false and the example that I
said earlier was one of these examples
where you have a random graph so okay so
why is this so so this initial version
is so false because if you take G and P
with P somewhat less than 1 over root n
and then remove an edge from each
triangle or just remove all the
triangles then you have a graph which is
still fairly pseudo-random but it has no
triangles so you cannot have a counting
number so there's another example which
in some sense is even better than this
random example and it's a somewhat
mysterious example do two alone that
gives you a pseudo-random gamma ok so
it's in some sense an optimally
pseudo-random gamma such that it is D
regular with T on the order of n to the
three halves and it's an ND lambda graph
where lambda is on the order of duty
okay so here T is not constant but even
in this case roughly speaking this is a
pseudo-random as you can expect so the
second eigenvalue is roughly square root
of T degree and yet this graph is
triangle free so you have some graph
which you know for all the other kinds
of pseudo randomness is very nice so it
has all the nice pseudo randomness
properties yeah it has still triangle
free it's sparse so the triangle
counting lemma is not true without
additional hypotheses
so I would like to add in some
hypotheses to make it true and I would
like a theorem okay I'm going to put as
a metal theorem which says that if you
assume that G is a sub graph of a
sufficiently pseudo-random gamma and
gamma has edge density P then the
conclusion is true and this is indeed
the case okay so this is indeed the case
I would like to tell you what is the
pseudo sufficiently pseudo-random what
is the hypothesis mean so that at least
you have some complete theorem to take
home there are several versions of this
term so let me give you one which I
really like because has a fairly clean
hypothesis and the version is that the
pseudorandomness condition so here's
sufficient pseudo randomness hypothesis
on gamma which is that gamma has the
correct number of correct correct in
quotes this is somewhat normative so
what I'm really saying is it has
compared to a random case where you
expect densities of all sub graphs of K
2 to 2 where
laughing correct density means density
having correct density of H means having
H density 1 plus little 1 times P raised
to number of edges of H which is what
you would expect in a random case so you
should think of there again not being
just one graph with a sequence of graphs
we can also equivalently write it down
in terms of deltas and epsilon is having
error parameters but I like to think of
it having a sequence of graphs just as
in what we did for quasi random graphs
if your gamma has this pseudo randomness
condition which is you know we're in the
sparse setting so if you try to compare
this to what we did for quasi random
graphs you might get confused because
they're having the correct C for count
already implies everything this
condition it actually does already
include having a correct C for count so
K 2 2 2 is this graph over here and I'm
saying that if it has all has the
correct density of H whenever H is a sub
graph of K 2 2 2 then it has a correct
density so in particular it already has
the C 4 count but I want more and turns
out this is genuinely more because in a
sparse setting having the correct C for
count is not equivalent to other notions
of pseudo randomness okay so this is
hypothesis so if I start with a sequence
of gammas the half the correct counts of
K 2 2 twos as well as sub graphs or k2
two twos then I claim that that pseudo
random host is good enough
to have a counting llama at least four
triangles any questions now you might
want to ask for some intuitions about
where this condition comes from I mean
the proof itself takes a few pages won't
try to do it here I might try to give
you some intuition how the proof might
go and also what are the difficulties
you might run into when you try to
execute this proof but the at least how
I think of it is that this K 2 2 2
condition place a role similar to how
previously in dense quasi random graphs
we had this somewhat magical looking C 4
condition which can be viewed as a
doubled version of edge actually there's
the technical name is called a blow up
there's a blow up of an edge whereas the
K 2 to 2 condition is a blow up as a to
blow up of a triangle and this to blow
up hypothesis is some kind of a graph
theoretic analog of controlling second
moment just as knowing the variance of a
random variable knowing in second moment
helps you to control the concentration
of that random variable showing that
it's fairly concentrated it turns out
that having this graphical second moment
in this sense also allows you to control
its properties so that you can have nice
tools like the counting lemma
so let me explain some of the
difficulties if you try to run the
original proof of the triangle removal
lemma for the spar setting what happens
so if you start with a vertex so
remember how the proof of triangle
removal Emma went you start with this
setup and you pick a typical vertex this
typical vertex has lots of neighbors to
the left and lots of neighbors to the
right and here a lot means roughly the
edge density times the number of
vertices and a lot of vertices over here
and then you say that because these are
two fairly large vertex s there are lots
of edges between them by the hypothesis
epsilon regularity between the bottom
two sets but now in the sparse setting
we have an additional factor of P so
these two sets are now quite small
they're much smaller than what you can
guarantee from the definition of epsilon
comma P regular so you cannot conclude
from them being epsilon regular that
there are enough edges between these two
very small sets so the strategy of
proving the triangle removal Emma breaks
down in the sparse setting
in general not just for triangles but
for other HS as well so we also have
this kind of counting lemma okay so the
sparse counting them up also the
triangle case which I stated earlier so
this is showing work due to : David :
Jacob Fox and myself says that there's a
counting llama so let me be very
informal so that there exists a sparse
counting lemma for counting H if so in
this setup as before if gamma has the
pseudo-random property of containing the
correct density of all sub graphs of the
two blow-up of H just as in the triangle
the to blow up is K 2 to 2 in general
the to blow up takes a graph H and then
doubles every vertex and put in four
edges between each pair of edges each
pair of vertices so that's the true
blow-up of age
if your gamma has quite pseudo-random
properties concerning counting sub
graphs of this to blow up then you can
obtain a counting number for H itself
any questions ok so let's take this
counting lemma for granted for now how
do we proceed to the proving the sparse
triangle removal lemma
well I claim that actually it's the same
proof where you run the usual summer and
irregularity proof of triangle remover
but now with all of these extra tools
and these extra hypotheses you then
would obtain the sparse triangle removal
lemma which I stated earlier and the
hypothesis that I left out the
sufficiently pseudo random hypothesis on
gamma is precisely this hypothesis over
here as required by the counting lemma
ok and once you have that then you can
proceed to prove a relative version of
Roth's theorem and also by extension to
hyper graphs also relative version of
similarity theorem so recall that the
Roth's theorem tells you that if you
have a sufficiently large let me first
write down roster and then I'll add in
the extra relative things in yellow so
if I start with a the subset of Z mod n
such that a has size at least
Delta n then
okay so then Rothstein tells us that a
contains at least 1/3 term arithmetic
progression but actually you can boost
that term and you've seen some examples
of this in homework and also our proofs
also do this exact same thing if you
look at any of the proofs that we've
seen so far it tells us that they not
only contains one single three AP but it
contains many create keys where C is
some number that is positive okay so you
can obtain this by the versions we've
seen before either by looking at a proof
problem see the proof gives that or by
using the black box version of
Gloucester and then there's a
supersaturation argument which is
similar to things we've done in the
homework what we would like is a
relative version and a relative version
will say that if you have a set s which
is sufficiently pseudo-random and s has
density P
and now a is a subset of s and a has
size at least
Delta nine of s then a contains still
lots of three a piece but I need to
modify the quantity because I'm looking
at density P okay so this statement is
also true if you're putting the
appropriate hypothesis into sufficiently
pseudo-random and what should those
hypothesis be so think about the proof
of Roth's theorem that one that we've
done where you set up a graph so you set
up this graph so one way to do this is
that you say that you put in edges
between the three parts XY and Z so the
vertex sets are all given by Z mod N and
you put in an edge between XY and Z if
between x and y if X plus okay so if 2x
plus y lies in s put in an edge between
X and Z if X minus Z lies in s and a
third edge between y and z if minus y
minus two Z lies in s so this is a graph
that we constructed in a proof of Roth's
theorem and when you construct this
graph either for s or for a as we did
before then we see that the triangles in
this graph correspond precisely to this
three a piece in the set so looking at
the triangle counting lemma and triangle
removal lemma the sparse versions then
you can read out what type of pseudo
randomness conditions you would like on
s so from this graph
so we would like a condition which says
that this graph here which we'll call
gamma sub s to half the the earlier
pseudorandomness
hypotheses and you can spell this out
and let's do that so let's actually
spell this out so what does this mean
so what I mean this s being a subset of
Z mod n we say that is satisfies what's
called a three linear forms condition if
for uniformly chosen random X naught X 1
y naught y 1 Z naught C 1 elements of Z
mod NZ think about this K 2 to 2 right
so draw a K 2 2 2 up there so what are
the edges corresponding to the K 2 2 2
also they correspond to the following
expressions - why not - to Z naught
minus y 1 minus 2 Z naught minus y
naught minus 2 Z 1 minus y 1 minus 2 Z 1
ok so that's those are the edges
corresponding to the bottom if you draw
a c4 across the bottom two vertex sets
but then there are two more columns and
I'll just buy some examples but you can
fill in the rest
okay so there are these twelve
expressions and what we would like is
that for random got the probability that
probability that all of these numbers
are contained in s is within one plus
little one factor of the expectation if
s were a random set in other words in
this case is P raise to 12 random set of
density P and furthermore the same holds
if any subset of these twelve
expressions are erased
okay now I want you to use your
imagination and think about what the
theorem would look like for not three
P's before for a piece and also for K
please in general so there's a relative
sonority theorem which tells you that if
you start with s so here we're fixed
okay if you start with us s that
satisfies kalyan your forms condition
and a it's a subset of s that is fairly
large then a has okay so I'm being
slightly sloppy here but that's the
spirit of the theorem that you have the
cemre ID term inside a sparse
pseudo-random set as long as the
pseudo-random self satisfies the scale
in your forms condition and that Kalyan
your forms condition is an extension of
this three linear forms condition where
you write down the proof that we saw for
summer Ali's theorem using hypergraphs
write down the corresponding linear
forms you expand them out and then you
write down this statement
okay so this version is this is
basically what I did for my PhD thesis
okay so you can ask well what what the
green-tailed you write so they they had
the original term back in 2006 so their
theorem which also was a relative
similarity term has some additional more
technical hypotheses known as
correlation conditions which I won't get
into but at the end of the day they
constructed the pseudo primes and then
they verified that those primes pseudo
Prime's satisfied these required pseudo
randomness hypotheses those pseudo
Prime's
satisfied these linear froms conditions
as well as there are no extraneous
additional pseudo randomness hypotheses
and then combining this combinatorial
theorem with that number theoretic
result you put them together you obtain
that the the preen Greenhow theorem
which tells you not just that the primes
contain arbitrarily long arithmetic
progressions but any positive density
subsets of the primes also contains
arbitrarily long arithmetic progressions
all of these terms all of these terms
now if you pass down to a relatively
then subset it still remains true any
questions so this is the general method
so the general method is you have the
sparse regularity method and provided
that you have a good counting lemma you
can transfer the entire method to the
sparse setting but getting the counting
lemma is often quite difficult and there
still interesting open problems in
particular what kind of pseudo
randomness hypothesis do we really need
another thing is that you don't actually
have to go through regularity yourself
so there's an additional method which
unfortunately I don't have to don't have
time to discuss called transference
where the story I've told you is that
you look at the proof of relative of
Roth's theorem the proof of similarities
and you transfer the methods of those
proofs to the spar setting and you can
do that but it turns out you can do
something even better is that you can
transfer the results and this is what
happens in green towel if you look at
some release term as a black box theorem
and you're happy with its statement you
can use these methods to transfer that
result as a black box without knowing
it's proof to the sparse pseudo-random
setting so and that sounds almost too
good to be true it's worth seeing how it
goes and if you want to learn more about
this subject so I have a there's a
survey by Colin Fox and by myself called
a queen cloud theorem and Exposition
okay so where you'll find a
self-contained complete proof of the
Queen Katherine except no modulo the
proof of summer Alice term which we
called as a black box but you see how
the transference method works there and
involves many of the things that we've
discussed so far in this course
including discussions of the regularity
method the counting lemma and will
contain a proof of this sparse triangle
counting them we stopped